my neighbor um answered the door and he
um had a he's looked really down and I
and I said what's up and he goes I lost
my job man I'm you know and I'm really
really scared and worried and he was
really down and I said to Liz oh I know
I said I talked to him about some stuff
that some ideas I like techniques that I
you know have that have worked for me
about it's kind of had a kind of mindset
you know and and he was getting it and
then I said and can I just give you
something I said you should try to work
out and start working out and I swear to
God like I don't care miss twenty
minutes but I could tell his body he
doesn't do a lot of that I said I
promise you not only will you feel
better but you kind of be able to think
straight and it was so interesting how
he looked at me like I was a crazy
person because it just it sounded like
holding he's probably 45 and lost his
job yeah and I and I and I was like and
he just looked meet our new intern Terry
he comes to Gary
I kind of thought meet heart in turn
hire my own DM me Gary 45 doesn't know
what a podcast is but he's our new
intern ever exercise cause an exercise
never heard of this show and so a lot of
times you know I wrestle with the idea
of defining myself in a certain way and
I've tried to write a script many many
times so after a while you go I'm not a
writer and it's really easy to fall into
that you know and then you talk to
writers and they go oh you're just doing
it wrong you know try this and then you
get a little closer to it but it's
really hard to not define yourself you
know especially as you get older and
especially as people know you as a
certain thing sometimes the people that
are around you are really good at
defining you and keeping you within
certain yeah you got to give up all that
[ __ ] you got to surrender all your claim
to who you think you are and just be
like I am I [ __ ] am and I'm gonna do
stuff and I'm gonna do stuff I am and
I'm gonna do stuff like that's all I'm
gonna be defended in the beginning yeah
in the beginning it may be bad at it I
love Rogen's think conquer your inner
[ __ ] yeah I've always liked that
because you know I'm gonna be bad at it
but your Rogen's secret I'll tell you a
secret right now all Rogan does is this
he goes all right I want to be good at
archery
or I want to
good running or I wanna be good at
jujitsu I'm gonna show up every day I'm
gonna suck I know I'm gonna suck for the
first year maybe four months I don't
what it is I'm gonna suck but the
difference between everybody else in me
is I'll be there every day maybe it'll
be a half hour might be an hour but I'll
be there every day just consistency and
you just get better yeah you don't
identify with any of the external things
you're not an archer right off about a
course you're not an archer you're not a
comic before you've ever gone on stage
you're not any of these things that you
want to be you you are and you do stuff
that's it's like it's super simple you
give up the rest just give it all away
somebody somebody pushed something on
you oh thanks for that compliment thanks
for calling me this day you're talking
about play schiller my favorite things
Schiller said man is never more himself
than when at play and plays not hookers
and speed ball play is the thing you do
for the sake of its own doing like the
thing you do for free anyway there's
something [ __ ] really fun about
getting good at something you know even
if it's tiny little increments a pitcher
the first-ever NFL male cheerleaders are
here I don't approve with the Los
Angeles Rams you're joking
I don't approve it's real
congratulations to our 2018 no nope nope
nope nope nope I don't want to why is
our society changing like this well I'm
all about eat buy oh my god alright and
all that [ __ ] kiss all about gender
brother come on look how happy is we're
right there on the bottom right he's the
one that tossed the girls in there and
stuff yeah well it's hard where I
imagine if there's an area of those guys
are real athletes they get injured there
they're just as athletic play the little
clay ball man I just like fan stuff
although these guys can move but you
have to be very gay right I mean don't
you have war or no or your ladies make
use of all the hottest women in the
world you toss them in the air well I
guess it's straight as a bone they're
there all the way they were
they're so happy people want to know
what led to you wanting to try out to be
a cheerleader
you know I was at a Laker game the
Wednesday prior and I was like oh hold
on halftimes like he's so good he says
there's nothing I kind of love both of
them
I'm into it on various proteins I just
thought why not me like why can't I do
this so I called my friend Raquel and I
asked her when auditions were for the
RAM would Rock the pillson but hey but
of course to do can dance but of course
it's the LA squad that has it first but
of all of it look you know what I kind
of love it
I'm on board look I'm not mad yeah baby
shake it he's every bit as [ __ ] he's
good
that motherfucker's a trained dancer
dancer but we hear those auditions that
Quentin was referring to just have a
show with the Dallas Cowboys trying to
make the cut
they put them little [ __ ] yeah if you
want to be you know a cheerleader
I thought it was like they were male
shooters out there throwing girls in the
air I thought you me all-male - now he's
a cheerleader resident he's wearing
pom-poms a skirt though he told me
that's why I'd really respect him if he
had a skirt on you talk about
transgender then I'm just talking about
cross yesterday Russell Peters gets out
of his portion and I just yeah I love
him he's such a good guy Russell and but
I'm like you're talking about a comic
that plays to the Staples Center Russell
Pete do you know that oh I know things
huge internationally for internationally
as big as if yeah yeah like millions and
millions of millions of people what
about us it's just funny he's just you
you see these people that couldn't be
bigger they're a basically comedy rock
star mr. Pell shot is special there yeah
belly room
yeah and that crazy yeah Lucy case shot
a special there yep yep you know I'm
saying yeah yeah it's amazing
Russell's been doing a lot of jiu-jitsu
he's always doing Jitsu oh it's true my
thing is I see Russell I always want to
talk about Tommy he always gonna start
out fighting you know yeah final thought
coming then he just takes over in the
film out fighting everybody wants to be
what they're not Darren yeah I know
that's how it goes when I tried I did
some boxing yesterday and decided to go
to uh
do go you know I faked one way go down
keep my head down and get get in got
punched in the [ __ ] top of my head
that didn't feel good good for you
yeah I was good I worked out with your
boy Opry Marcus this morning oh really
boys in shape yes he is I set him up
with Glenn my trailer so we did MIT so I
minute on I would go to the bag when
you'd be on it then
vice versa did probably 40 minutes of
that and then we did a circuit after
that boys in shape though he's a
different shape but he's in shape
different shape different shape he's
definitely rolling yeah
well it's funny um here's my question
this is such a stupid question don't
answer this ours hands nothing honest
what what what did you say
well oh you talked about fighting for
real it's funny too because you always
talk about how the you know with
everybody talking like all of us all of
us civilians sparring or something and
the guy I was moving around with is a
very big guy and he played he fought
Golden Gloves and I think one in Boston
played semi-pro hockey a real athlete
and takes it easily that doesn't count
takes easy you say semi-pro yeah it
doesn't count doesn't matter just for me
he's just all done count though I played
basketball in high school he kind of hit
me lightly on my cranium like just
lightly he's not some words move around
it went Bob because I try this thing and
I went oh [ __ ] that that really hurt my
cranium it hurt my head hurry now if
you're sick you're sparring and you get
and somebody like just steps into it and
really hit that head gear does
absolutely nothing nothing it's like
alright zero don't don't spar unless
sure